hi in this video we're going to be
talking about the internet part 1 how
the internet works to know how the
internet works we're going to talk first
about IP addresses you might be familiar
with the fact that each of your devices
has its own IP address just like a house
or apartment has its own an actual
address the internet can't deliver data
to a device unless it has an IP address
not only does your device have an IP
address but so does the modem and the
router and every step along the way in
the internet which we'll get to later IP
addresses are determined based on
location starting in five big
international regions that's on this
side as you get down the line each of
these members brings you to a more
specific location now this number isn't
specific enough that you could call
9-1-1 give them your IP address and they
could find your house but it is specific
enough where if you google find the best
Ice Cream Sandwich near me Google can
help you out there and actually give you
something close to your location what I
want you to take away from this video is
that every device that connects to the
Internet has an IP address and that it
needs that IP address so the information
knows where to go